تايوان شأن داخلي
وليس لكم  شأن بها!!
هكذا قالها رئيس الصين لأمريكا،،
الصين قد احتلت منازلكم وقبل أن تفكروا
بحربها كل شيء في منازلكم
من صنع الصين، فهل بإمكانكم
أن تتخلوا عن أشيائكم التي صنعتها بكين؟
هل تأخذ الصين ورقة من كتاب قواعد
اللعبة الروسية؟، ..
"الصين ستغزو تايوان وأمريكا تحذر
وتتوعد، الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
استخدمت الترغيب والترهيب
لتثني أصحاب العيون الضيقة
عن احتلال تايوان فما الذي تنوي بكين
فعله يا ترى؟،
بينما توجه كل أعين العالم إلى أوكرانيا،
تعمل الصين بصمت والجزيرة التايوانية
تطبخ على نار بكين الهادئة،
والعالم يقف متفرجا،
المناورات الصينية على أشدها
والأسلحة والطائرات والصواريخ
قيد الاستعداد... البارجات وحاملات الطائرات
وراجمات الصواريخ الأمريكية
في البحر بالقرب من سواحل الصين وتايوان
، فهل أخذ التنين الصيني درسا من دب روسيا
فيكتفي الصينيون بهجوم واحد
لاستعادة الجزيرة التي قالوا أنهم فقدوها؟
العالم لا تنقصه الحروب
لكن الصين باستطاعتها أن تباغت
أقوى وأعتى الجيوش العالمية فكيف لها
ألا تغزو جزيرة كتايوان؟
(الحليف الأمريكي)
تعتبر تايوان إحدى الدول الحليفة لأمريكا في الشرق،
وقد حان الوقت ليبرهن الأمريكان
على ذلك،
وهنا خرج الرئيس الأميركي
جو بايدن، ليؤكد، أنّ الولايات المتحدة
ستدافع عسكرياً عن تايوان
"إذا ما شنّت الصين هجوماً"
على هذه الجزيرة،، فهل يكون وعد بايدن
لتايون كوعده لأوكرانيا؟
. إذ كان هذا التهديد قبل غزو موسكو
لكييف فهل يتغير بعد الغزو؟
والإجابة هنا لدى وزير خارجية أمريكا،
إنّه يتعيّن على الزعماء الصينيين
"التفكير ملياً" في تحركاتهم إزاء تايوان،
محذراً من "عواقب وخيمة" إذا حثّت الصين
الخطى نحو مضيق تايوان.
ما الذي ستفعله يا سيادة الوزير
هل ستفرض عقوبات اقتصادية على ملوك الاقتصاد؟
طُرح سؤال على الوزير مرة أخرى،
حول ما إذا كانت الصين ستغزو تايوان،
ليرد مرة أخرى
"سيكون قراراً يحتمل أن يكون كارثياً"،
مكرراً الموقف الأميركي نفسه بأنّ واشنطن
"ملتزمة بقوة" بضمان امتلاك تايوان
لوسائل الدفاع عن نفسها.
"دأبت الصين على محاولة تغيير الوضع
الراهن" عبر مضيق تايوان في السنوات الأخيرة،
من خلال "المشاركة في مناورات عسكرية
استفزازية ومحاولة عزل تايوان
عن بقية العالم".
بهذه الجمل شرح الأمريكان الوضع التايواني،
"لكن  الأمل يحدوهم في أن يفكر قادة الصين
ملياً في هذا الأمر، فالغزو لا يصب
في مصلحة أحد، بدءاً من الصين"
كما تقول واشنطن
يبدو أن أمل الإدارة الأمريكية سيكون وهما،
حيث قال وزير الدفاع التايواني
إنّ التوترات مع الصين "بلغت حداً غير مسبوق"
منذ أكثر من 40 عاماً، ويؤكد أنّ الصين
سيكون بإمكانها القيام "بغزو شامل"
للجزيرة بحلول 2025،،
لكن بعد حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا
هل تنتظر الصين كل هذه المدة لتغزو تايوان؟
(موقف الصين من الغزو)
بعد أن أفسحت روسيا المجال للصينيين بغزوها
لأوكرانيا، يجري أصحاب العيون الضيقة
استعداداتهم على قدم وساق لغزو تايوان
الجزيرة التي قالت بكين أنها كانت تابعة لها،
بكين ترى تايوان مقاطعة منشقة
سيعاد ضمها إلى البر الصيني في نهاية المطاف،
فيما يختلف الكثير من التايوانيين
مع وجهة نظر بكين،
إذ أنهم يرون أن لديهم أمة منفصلة،
سواء تم إعلان استقلالها رسميا أم لا.
وهنا حكومة الصين تدعو، واشنطن
إلى "التصرف بحذر بشأن تايوان"،
مؤكدة أنّ "الصين لن تفسح في المجال
لأي مساومة بشأن القضايا التي تتعلق
بمصالحها الجوهرية"، وذلك رداً
على تصريحات الرئيس الأميركي
جو بايدن بأنّ الولايات المتحدة  ستدافع
عن الجزيرة المتمتّعة بالحكم الذاتي
من أي هجموم محتمل من بكين.
بينما استدعت الصين سفير اليابان لديها
ووجهت رسالة شديدة اللهجة لطوكيو
التي قالت إنّ "حالة طوارئ لتايبيه
ستكون حالة طوارئ لليابان أيضاً".
الصين توضح لليابانيين أن لا ينخدعوا
بحليفهم الأمريكي كما انخدعت كييف من قبلهم..
(بداية المناورات)
ماهي إلا أيام قليلة بعد تولي بايدن كرسي الرئاسة
الأمريكية، حينها أبلغت تايوان
عن "توغل كبير" من قبل الطائرات
الحربية الصينية على مدى يومين.
أما بعد العمليات العسكرية الروسية بأوكرانيا
فقد عاش الشعب التايواني توترا وقلقا
منقطع النظير، فهناك أوجه تشابه عديدة
بين أوكرانيا وتايوان، نذكر منها:
أنهما دولتان صغيرتان جوار دولتين
عظيمتين تمتلكان أقوى جيوش العالم
وأقوى الأسلحة وأكثر عدد للجنود
مقارنة بمعظم الدول العالمية...
تايوان وأوكرانيا جزء من إمبراطوريات
عظيمة فتايوان كانت تابعة للصين
وأوكرانيا كنت من أراضي الاتحاد السوفييتي،
تمتلك تايوان وأوكرانيا أيضا الحليف ذاته
الذي يطلق الوعود يمنة ويسرة
لكنه لا يفي بها والدليل ما يحدث لكييف اليوم!!
(الواقع على الأرض)
ساعات من بدء الغزو الروسي لأوكرانيا
سارع بعدها سلاح الجو التايواني إلى التحذير
من دخول تسع طائرات عسكرية صينية
منطقة تحديد الدفاع الجوي فيها.
ليصدر تصريح رسمي صيني
أن "تايوان ليست أوكرانيا، بالطبع.
فلطالما شكّلت تايوان جزءاً لا يتجزأ
من أراضي الصين. هذه حقيقة تاريخية وقانونية
لا يمكن دحضها"، واتهمت بكين تايبيه والغرب
باستخدام أوكرانيا "للتضليل بشأن" التهديدات
العسكرية بشكل خبيث،
وتحريض المشاعر المعادية للصين.
بينما كان السفير الصيني لدى الولايات المتحدة
تشين جانغ، قد أثار الدهشة حينما ذكر
أن، قضية تايوان أكبر قنبلة خامدة بين الصين
والولايات المتحدة. وإذا استمرت السلطات التايوانية،
بتشجيع من الولايات المتحدة،
في السير على طريق الاستقلال،
فمن المرجح أن تنخرط الصين والولايات المتحدة،
وهما دولتان كبيرتان، في صراع عسكري"
الصين تراقب الإجراءات الغربية عن كثب،
وتركز على مدى إمكانية أن تغزو تايوان
بنجاح.(هكذا قالها الأمريكيون بأنفسهم)
فهل من ردة فعل أمريكية على ذلك؟
لم يعد السؤال هل" بل متى تقدم الصين
على غزو تايوان؟ مؤشرات عديدة تؤكد
أن "ساعة الصفر" ربما تكون قد حُددت بالفعل
من جانب بكين
أرسلت بكين عددا هائلا من الطائرات
الصينية إلى منطقة الدفاع الجوي لتايوان،
على مدى 5 أيام وبتشكيلات متنوعة
وفي أوقات متعددة، وليس هذا فحسب
فخلال عام واحد أرسلت بكين عشرات الطائرات
الحربية لتخترق الأجواء التايوانية
وهذا يحكي القصة على الأرض باختصار..
يشير اختلال ميزان القوة بين تايوان وجارتها
القوة العظمى، اللتين يفصلهما أقل من 81 ميلاً
(130.4 كيلومتر) عند أضيق نقطة
في مضيق تايوان، إلى أنَّ الغزو الصيني
سيكون سريعاً ومُظفَّراً.
لكن ما يعقد الأمر قليلا هو الموقف الأميركي
من الغزو،
،قبل عامين قررت واشنطن
بيع تايوان قاذفات صواريخ تكتيكية
مقابل 436 مليون دولار ومعدّات تصوير
للاستطلاع الجوي مقابل 367 مليون دولار،
لتصل بذلك القيمة الإجمالية لهذه المبيعات
إلى أكثر من 1.8 مليار دولار.
تشير التقارير إلى أن بكين ستخاطر
باستباق محاولة إنقاذ أمريكية بشن هجمات
بالصواريخ الباليستية أو القاذفات
على قاعدة غوام،
في البحر هناك ثلاث حاملات
طائرات أمريكية عملاقة في جزيرة
يابانية قريبة من سواحل تايوان والصين،
وعلى متنها أقوى الطائرات الحربية
والمقاتلات،
لكن الصين من جانبها
ردت بتكثيف مناوراتها العسكرية البحرية
بعشرة ألوية من الجيش الصيني
تنفذ تدريبات في السواحل الشرقية،
فضلا عن إجراء جيشي الصين وروسيا
مناورات عسكرية في الأراضي الصينية
وب١٠آلاف جندي وتحت شعار
التعاون بين البلدين الحليفين،
الصين تتجهز بترسانة صواريخ كبيرة
وبحشد عسكري بالقرب من تايوان،
ويعد هذا الحشد هو الأكبر  للصين منذ الحرب العالمية الثانية
مجلة (The Economist) البريطانية الشهيرة،
وصفت جزيرة تايوان بأنها
«أخطر مكان على وجه الأرض»، لما تمثله
من معضلة كبيرة للصين وللولايات المتحدة
معا.
فالصين وإن كانت جاهزة لاجتياح
الجزيرة  إلا أنها ليست متأكدة أن الرد الأمريكي
سيكون كما ردت أمريكا على غزو أوكرانيا،
في حين تقول التقارير أن بكين لن تنتظر لأكثر
من عام قبل غزو تايوان، فما الذي سيفعله
أصحاب العيون الضيقة يا ترى؟